are we on the wrong show is this hot
ones
you know water just spreads it all down
right
[Music]
[Music]
buffalo chicken pizza is the OG
specialty slice that nearly every piece
of joint offers but what happens when
you take the concept of a chicken wing
inspired pie and crank it up to
outrageous New Heights there's only one
man crazy enough for this Challenge and
that's Mike Howe from Tony baloney's
Mike served me a crushing defeat in
season one but now I finally get my
chance in Revenge a battle that's heated
deserves a pair of legendary judges Lil
yachty is the rap game's most outspoken
Pizza lover and Carla Hall is a food TV
Trailblazer who doesn't mess around when
it comes to her slices will the lemon
pepper Pizza I'm whipping up for Yadi be
enough to match Mike's flaming hot
buffalo chicken it's game on
Mike Houck welcome back to Pizza Wars
thank you I'm glad to be back it's been
a minute but I'm pumped today we're
gonna have fun but more importantly I'm
gonna [ __ ] win this competition
nothing's on fire right do I need a
Hazmat I actually hope you win I hope
you win
look at that come on what a competition
show you know so today it's all about
chicken wing pizza so today I'm gonna do
our own Tony baloney's take on a
traditional Buffalo pizza because
everyone has buffalo chicken on their
menu [ __ ] everyone we don't give a damn
we're not gonna do that so we have our
own interesting Twist on it and we're
gonna do just that today let's go so
step one it all starts with the dough I
can't wait to hear about this stuff so
this is actually like a flaming hot
Cheeto dough yes all right then we're
gonna stick it inside of these ground up
flaming hot Cheetos and we're gonna use
it as a flower pull it out a little bit
drive the car I'm not driving the car
today I'm driving the boat I'm driving
the yacht little yachty style actually
these shoes there's a whistle I'll be
the captain let's do it
right all the board or whatever you say
I'm gonna kick the shoe off I'll do that
later then we're gonna move on to some
of our toppings we're using Sicilian
chili but we're gonna spread it out
really nice and easy we're gonna put
some dry aged mozzarella sounds good on
this pizza all right now the next thing
is the chicken we made a Cool Ranch
Dorito buttermilk batter and then on top
of that we took buffalo potato chips and
then coated it in the potato chips okay
we're gonna put a few on the pie all
right nice and liberally last thing
we're going to do we're going to take
our mozzarella this is Buffalo
mozzarella not Buffalo like those nasty
things with the horns I'm talking about
buffalo in terms of buffalo chicken that
looks creative as fun let's go I love it
and
[Music]
all right Nicole pizza game out of the
oven now it's not fully finished yet but
what do you think I think it's beautiful
and you know what it looks like it looks
like a snack
it does look at it's so snack of your
snack snack the whole snack and we're
gonna top it off now with little boat
coolest ranch dressing only meant for
little Yachts only met for the Seven
Seas all right Cheers Cheers
[Applause]
oh my God no this is delicious it's good
this is the best buffalo chicken pizza
I've ever seen in my life I got some
[ __ ] on my face no
this is so good I'm gonna kill my
friends now yeah yeah I mean I like it
well I'm excited for your pizza mine's
gonna be super simple super simple this
is amazing and I love all the effort you
put in here Bravo thank you that means a
lot coming from you
okay Mike so you made a fantastic
buffalo chicken pizza Bravo to you thank
you thank you thank you and you know
what I'm gonna do today tell me I'm
gonna make a lemon pepper chicken pizza
oh [ __ ] it's over it's actually super
simple
I love lemon pepper me too Lil yachty
from Atlanta area he's gonna love lemon
pepper I hope he does oh my God I'm
making it just for him I'm starting with
my regular pizza dough and I'm just
gonna start building this right on the
peel you're going with the red base I
think the lemon pepper chicken with the
sauce is gonna be good all right so we
got our cheese down to make it a Super
Lemon I have my lemon pepper sauce and
I'm just gonna dot the crust get a
little buttery lemon crust going on is
that sesame seeds yeah sesame seeds just
a little crunch I love sesame seeds all
right you know the base of my pie is
done so I'm gonna throw it in the oven
beautiful
[Music]
so I took my pie Out the Oven Midway
through I want to just put my lemon
pepper chicken on get a little crisp in
the oven what the [ __ ] is that over
there holy [ __ ] what is that
I'll try one what do you put in your
lemon pepper sauce typically I put
butter a little olive oil fresh lemon
rind fresh lemon juice sometimes you
gotta add a little garlic just to give
it a little something you know I'm just
gonna let this cook up a little bit more
looks unbelievable
okay Mike my pieces came out of the oven
what do you think so far that crust is
absolutely insane like it always is cool
yeah I love it that's my kind of pizza I
like a drippy Oozy Pizza
oh my god oh good you like super poppy
thank you super crispy a lot of flavor I
mean you hear that
well there you have it lemon pepper
chicken killed it thank you so much you
made an amazing buffalo chicken pizza I
love my lemon pepper pizza now will the
judges like it we've got Carla Hall here
food TV icon I mean I've always wanted
to meet her so this means a lot to me
that she's going to be here today
judging our pizza and we have rap Legend
little yachty in the building no it's
insane get obsessed with peace I mean
this guy loves me so he even has a
frozen pizza wow so you ready yeah I'm
ready let's go let's do this let's go
first up oh wow this is the lemon pepper
chicken pizza okay bring my light to us
boys
I have pizza last night in that [ __ ]
[ __ ] my stomach oh oh my God
I was [ __ ] for two hours let's talk
about it it's gonna sound crazy it's
gonna sound like a flex but I was at
Drake's house and his Chef made me a
pizza it was honestly the best pizza I
ever had in my life and I was like all
this business to die for and then
literally I was like about to die it was
crazy yeah
oh wow it's a lot of cheese yeah
oh oh oh okay
oh
[Music]
it's going straight in there
oh man
is that a good old man oh it's good no
from Atlanta right
so lemon pepper chicken is like a thing
we the only black people in here but
it's a thing for black people so I was
expecting it not to be a thing
I don't know who made this but this
thing
[Music]
so for you
it's good it makes you want to keep
eating it I think this one's really hard
to eat though because it's heavy it is
so the chicken's gonna fall off but I
would never grade something on if it's
hard to eat I'm going on taste
and you know what
you know what I like about the crust it
has salt in it and you still it still
tastes kind of yeasty I want to know
what that Crush tastes like but I don't
like sesame seeds
take 115.
you may like take one for the team okay
I don't know
see what the team say
s
you're welcome okay Auntie Carla's not
gonna steer you wrong and so I love this
chicken that said I think some of the
pieces were really large like you have a
whole half of your chicken that's the
only thing the chicken's too big but
that said when you have good fried
chicken you almost needed to be a
certain size so it doesn't dry out all
right this pizza was great but we have
one more to try let's do it
second pizza's up what do you think I do
like
hot Cheeto crusted things
I like when things are crushed to watch
those I really do okay but I do not I'm
not I'm not a buffalo chicken guy okay I
don't really like spicy things cheers
but look it actually holds out really
well right it's easier to eat
[Music]
are we on the wrong show is this hot
ones
okay
okay
you know water just spreads it all down
right
actually it was hot but if you like
Buffalo then you would love it right
because it's like oh God it's so crunchy
I just don't like Buffalo it's too hot
but that hot chill [ __ ] is busting I
love that hot Cheeto crust I want to
bite it again but it was so hot but you
know what I like about this look you see
the chicken on that bite
it's not weight down everything is
perfect about this pizza and if you love
buffalo if you like hot not even buffalo
hot you would just die for this pizza
right like it's really cool you do this
hot [ __ ] because you just going for it I
am I'm ready for hot ones [ __ ] hard ones
so you've been on hot ones twice
how you do
all right yaddy we've had two amazing
pizzas we have to decide on which is the
best one we have to pick a winner are
you ready let's do it I'm ready all
right
yachty Carla it's amazing to have you
guys here thank you for joining us on
Pizza Awards thank you
thank you thank you for having us this
is a lot harder than it looks I was
excited to come first of all both pizzas
were really great amazing this one here
with the crust which was yeasty the
light tomato sauce all of the cheese the
chicken almost felt like chicken that
you would just have on a side plate that
was with rolls or whatever it was hard
to eat because the chicken was so heavy
but that didn't stop us did it no it
didn't it was really good right yeah I
don't know who made it but when it came
out I looked the room and I said there's
no black people in here and this is
lemon pepper chicken so I know it's not
gonna be right and then I had it I was
like damn
and then a black person I was like I
know who made that [ __ ] I know who made
that chicken the only way to know only
we could make that [ __ ] like that you
know what I'm saying go be wrong but I
know chickens and then this one is a lot
easier to eat and then like flaming Red
Hot Cheetos like whoa I thought that was
the most amazing I love flaming hot
Cheeto dust so like under the crust and
on the crust and I just like I was like
this is good you know it was really good
it was really really really really
really good it just ate really well yeah
it was just too hot for me I was like
too bite
you know like it was really hot okay
guys can't take it any longer
who's the winner well we actually have
decided if you give us three two one we
will each point to the pizza that we
think should win all right three
two one
[Applause]
that was my choice too by the way that
was my winner I just really appreciate
you guys so much of this no losers
because right no they were both amazing
it's freaking amazing I would go back to
that pizza I was almost embarrassed at
how much I like this piece no the crust
I just never thought of it it was like
sick all right well thank you
congratulations
thanks for joining us again by the way
this is a good setup because I won the
first time around you won the second
time around one more time
thank you guys so much thank you so much
and see you next time on Pete's Awards
[Music]